il y a des choses assez curieux je sais
pas si elles sont symbolique si elles
sont à sens profond
S qui reflète à la fois la qualité la
technique et le lieu
il y a derrière la tête de Gainsbourg
une tarentule venimeuse
tiens voilà
c'est ça le métier arrivé au bon moment
la pêche
est-ce que l'on peut dire aujourd'hui en
73 que nous sommes aujourd'hui entrée à
la maison d'un peintre raté dans la
maison d'un artiste de variété qui a
connu la réussite
[Musique]
ralentir parce que c'est justement ça
quelque chose qui
c'est le téléphone ça oui c'est pas le
[Musique]
coiffeurs de la variété mais j'ai laissé
le bateau
de la peinture à la dérive
le Radeau de la Méduse
qu'est-ce que ça représente aujourd'hui
avec le recul
mais une initiation
la peinture ça implique à jamais le sens
de l'esthétique
de la beauté des valeurs
artistique réelle
est-ce qu'il y a des instants au début
de votre carrière plus pas exactement au
début d'ailleurs mais à d'autres époques
de votre carrière artistique où vous
avez
c'est une présentation de toute la
famille si j'ai bientôt c'est très bien
je dois dire d'abord Jane l'enfant et le
chien derrière
il est très beau puisqu'on ne peut pas
présenter puisque le destin enfin votre
vie ou votre décision que vous lutte que
vous ayez détruit un jour c'est toi
parce que je ne sais pas parce que
j'étais en évolution et je me suis pas
je me mettais pas trouvé c'est pour ça
que vous pouvez pas parler de peintre
ratés
chasse l'autre chaque toile
détruisait j'aime détruire
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce jour
mais
pourquoi vous aimez détruire
de survie parce que je voyais pas la
peinture
avec très peu d'argent
vous savez les les restaurateurs de
tableaux ont plus de travail avec
les impressionnistes et cubistes qu'avec
les qu'avec les
il y a du moyen
mais pour ça il faut un mécène et pour
avoir un médecin
je me méfie toujours ce qui se passe
derrière moi
alors un beau jour la variété
j'ai décidé d'être mon propre
[Musique]
soleil sous la terre drôle de se croiser
etc
ça je j'aimerais détruire aussi mais je
peux pas c'est graver et puis c'est ça
j'aimerais détruire ces premières
chansons pourquoi
pour les besoins de me détruire et de
renouveler
que ce n'est pas c'était comme la
peinture c'est pas valable en soi c'est
pas
ça n'est pas
[Musique]
immobile dans le temps
un peu de bac
[Musique]
actuellement parce que quand mon père
m'a prenait ça je pleurais
parce qu'il avait une voix forte et
autoritaire il admettait pas que son
fils soit mal à moi
il est mort
et en mettant en plastique
c'est un mot très fort très dur qu'on a
appliqué souvent est-ce qu'à l'époque
vous avez conscience de cette étiquette
est-ce que ça vous gêne dans vos
rapports
dans la vie réelle maintenant je suis
arrivé
ce problème sont faussés je suis beau je
suis superbe j'ai de l'argent j'ai
réussi
mais j'étais un petit pianiste
j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas vous mon amour
toujours aussi sage
libertin possible c'est un cadeau de le
dire
je crois que c'est quoi c'est qu'est-ce
que c'est ça c'est indien c'est quoi
c'est cher
les oiseaux
[Musique]
je t'aime je t'aime
moi je te couperai les doigts pour avoir
mes bagues
alors voilà ça c'était la
la
salle de bain mais
[Musique]
je rentre jamais
moi je me lève avec ça avant je me
lavais les deux mains avec les deux
mains puis après je me suis servi avec
une main maintenant j'ai trouvé quelque
chose de mieux
[Musique]
c'est pas des blagues en fait c'est vrai
je fais quelques raccords
de temps en temps dans la salle de bain
c'est pas fini parce que il faut que je
mette des
feux des photos je pense
je voulais faire un chemin de croix de
Marilyn Monroe ici c'est une photo de
Marilyn Monroe je jetterai des clous
sur la gueule
et je prendrai une prise de cette photo
je recommencerai selon le
clou lui mangeons la gueule ça peut être
intéressant
et puis là alors
la bibliothèque
c'est là je que je travaille
j'ai le ciel j'ai un arbre
aujourd'hui il commence à avoir des
feuilles
alors c'est un peu plus sombre en été
mais c'est gay et plus clair en hiver
plus triste
c'était
au voleur cambrioleurs éventuel que
c'est un verbe blindé
il faut mettre deux plans
[Musique]